das deutsche nein zur lieferung von
kampfpanzern in die ukraine es könnte
jetzt kippen und das liegt an diesem
interview bild reporter paul ronzheimer
mit eu-kommissionschef in ursula von der
leyen und in diesem gespräch sagt sie
die oberste eu schiffe in diesem satz
wenn sie sagen sie brauchen kampfpanzer
dann sollten wir das ernst nehmen
sollten ihnen das liefern sie haben in
den letzten monaten bewiesen wehren uns
dann die anfangs diskussion im februar
sie haben in den letzten monaten
bewiesen dass sie genau wissen was sie
brauchen um ihre leben zu schützen und
sich zu verteidigen
also die mächtigste eu politikerin die
macht druck auf die bundesregierung
jetzt in der panzer frage
waffen ja panzer nein das ist die
antwort der bundesregierung auf alle
panzer anfragen aus der ukraine seit
monaten
doch jetzt machten sie druck die
deutsche eu kommissionschef in ursula
von der leyen ich finde ganz wichtig die
ukrainer beweisen ja dass sie wenn sie
die richtigen militärischen mittel haben
sich verteidigen können und sie kämpfen
diesen kampf für uns alle das ist der
kampf dass die demokratie siegt und die
autokratie verliert druck aus brüssel in
der panzer frage druck auf den kanzler
der klettert für gute fotos auf panzer
sagt aber weiterhin nein zu panzern für
die ukraine und auch sie sagt nein die
verteidigungsministerin trotz aller
bitten aus kiew nur mit modelle waffen
moderne technologie können wir diesen
krieg stoppen und russland stoppen
deswegen ist es notwendig dass die
leopards geliefert werden die reaktion
der bundesregierung auf all diese sätze
sie liefert nun diese dingos gepanzerte
fahrzeuge aber eben keine kampfpanzer
wie den leopard wenn sie sagen sie
brauchen kampfpanzer dann sollten wir
das das liefert das panzer machtwort der
eu kommissionschef in bei bild live es
ist nun das politische diskussionsthema
worte die im kanzleramt nach hallen
werden wenn sie sagen sie brauchen
kampfpanzer dann sollten wir das ernst
ihm und sollten ihnen das liefern
worte die nachhallen worte die auch
druck erzeugen können paul ronzheimer
und zugeschaltet aus der ukraine
worte die einen so großen druck erzeugen
können dass aus dem nein vielleicht doch
noch ein jahr wird pop
das ist gut möglich patricia ist es
definitiv ein einmaliger politischer
vorgang dass die eu
kommissionspräsidenten in einem
interview sagt die eu staaten sollen
kampfpanzer liefern das hat es noch
nicht gegeben es ist so die europäer
haben keine eigene armee das wollte man
zwar immer hat das lang nicht geklappt
und normalerweise ist jedes land selbst
dafür zuständig dafür verantwortlich
aber es zeigt auch dass ursula von der
leyen sehr beeindruckt ist von dem was
sie hier in kiew gehört hat was sie
gesehen hat sie hat mit vielen menschen
gesprochen so wie wir auch in diesen
regionen unterwegs zumindest hier rund
um kirche und hat gemerkt dass mehr
unterstützung so sagt sie notwendig ist
und wären sie dieses interview geführt
hat mit uns da saß olaf scholz in
potsdam der bundeskanzler und musste
sich das was ursula von der leyen uns
erzählt hat auch dort anhören wladimir
klitschko der bruder von vitali
klitschko den bürgermeister in kiew hat
dort ebenfalls kampfpanzer gefordert und
klare worte an den bundeskanzler
gerichtet also die eu kommissionschef in
dem gespräch mit paul druck macht auf
die bundesregierung jetzt eben doch
kampfpanzer zu liefern in die ukraine
das wollen wir nochmal innenpolitisch
hier beleuchten mit unserem bild politik
chef jan schäfer christ ich schwimme mit
morgen jan o die panzer wende die
kampfpanzer wende wie dicht stehen wir
da vor also es ist noch keine wende paul
ronzheimer das glaube ich gerade ganz
richtig gesagt es bemerkenswert dass
eu-kommissionspräsident in von allein so
vorgeprescht ist die eu und auch frau
von der leyen war bisher nicht statt
bisher nicht im verdacht besonders vorne
bei einer entwicklung zu stehen das tut
sie jetzt sie ist damit politisch
gesehen die spitzenkraft gab noch keinen
so prominenten
außenpolitiker oder überhaupt
internationalen politiker der das so
gesagt hat wie frau von der leyen und
die frage ist genau richtig wie streit
das jetzt innenpolitisch auf olaf scholz
beispielsweise ab oder scholz befindet
sich in einer absoluten kriegs zange so
kann man es vielleicht einmal
beschreiben er steht ist kanzler einer
partei die alles andere als dafür ist
kampfpanzer beispielsweise in die
ukraine zu schicken dann hat er zwei
koalitionspartner fdp und grüne die
dringend darauf seit wochen kampfpanzer
zu schicken und natürlich ist olaf
scholz auch eingebunden in ein
internationales geflecht stichwort nato
und da sind die usa dominierend und wir
hören auch aus den usa dass es da immer
noch eine gewisse zurückhaltung gibt von
us präsident joe biden das kann
zusammenhängen mit den sogenannten
midterms den wahlen die am 8 november in
den usa stattfinden das bedeutet
möglicherweise danach ist es viel
einfacher und viel leichter kampfpanzer
in die ukraine zu schicken wenn es noch
einmal mitte die ein gemenge lage in der
ampel der ist man sich derzeit ja bei
einigen themen nicht einig wer steht
jetzt bei der lieferung von den
kampfpanzern auf dem gaspedal und wer
blockiert das ganze doch ich halte nicht
mal über die parteigrenzen kann man sich
da genau orientieren ja aber man muss
sagen gerade die grünen die ja
eigentlich eine sehr pazifistische
partei waren beziehungsweise diesen
pazifismus auch immer wie eine monstranz
vor sich her getragen haben die haben
sich sehr sehr geändert und gedreht in
der ganzen debatte auch natürlich weil
viele politiker wie annalena baerbock
mehrmals vor ort gewesen sind und
gesehen haben was da genau passiert in
der ukraine so und da ist zb annalena
baerbock die bundes außenministerin eine
ganz starke befürworterin von
lieferungen von kampfpanzern aber toni
hofreiter beispielsweise sieht das
genauso und fdp in der fdp gibt es
ebenfalls viele viele prominente
vertreter beispielsweise agnes strack
zimmermann die chefin des
verteidigungsausschusses die ja auch
schon seit wochen dafür trommelt
kampfpanzer endlich zu schicken hat die
bundesregierung ja längst schwere
artilleriegeschütze geschickt schickt
jetzt diese dinge wie wir es gerade
gezeigt haben macht das jetzt ein
riesenunterschied ob man leopard schickt
oder ein dingo schickt oder ein schweres
artilleriegeschütz naja ist ein
unterschied ob ich ein transportpanzer
schicke oder ob ich ein leo schicke
einen richtigen kampfpanzer der also
auch in einem richtigen gefecht bestehen
kann und russische panzer dann zerstören
würde und massiv zerstören könnte das
ist schon ein unterschied und wir hören
ja aus der ukraine seiten monaten dass
es die briten und die rufe gibt
kampfpanzer zu schicken interessant ist
dass es eine gewisse wende gibt die wir
sehen deutliche rückgewinnung der
ukrainischen armee das war von
amerikanern auch angekündigt und zwar
angekündigt für ungefähr die zeit mitte
ende august genau das ist eingetreten
das hat damit zu tun dass es mehr
waffenlieferungen gibt an die ukraine
hat mit zu sichern geldflüssen zu tun
die an die ukraine gehen und deswegen
glaube ich ist die debatte über die
kampfpanzer nicht mehr aufzuhalten die
rollt die leute und frau von der leyen
ist jetzt in vorleistung gegangen und
lasst uns abwarten spätestens ist meine
prognose ab mitte november wird es diese
kampfpanzer geben den schneefall vielen
herzlichen dank für deine einschätzungen
zu diesem thema am heutigen morgen
[Musik]